hey Brendo caucus no you haven't you're
a lion dogface pony soldier you said you
are but you know you gotta be honest I'm
gonna be up there with Charlie Sheen's
droopy-eyed armless children if Biden is
the Democrat winds up going head-to-head
with Trump which is seeming increasingly
likely what do you think is going to be
what do you think will be his downfall
or ultimately what are you looking to
there's I enjoy at this point I just
want to let the games begin
[Laughter]
I don't think he would win but I don't
have the same kind of I guess sort of
disdain for him like I do for Nancy
Pelosi or LC or even Barack Obama he's
probably the least consequential
Democrat I can think of he's just there
I agree we're starting to feel a little
sorry for him to it a little bit I do
feel sorry for now until you realize
that that Joe Biden Vice President Joe
Biden here's what I want to talk about
he hates his own voters this is what's
so funny we're gonna go that our exam
these aren't examples of him chastising
of him berating people who oppose him
Brent these are people who support him
so can you imagine if we had video home
supporters he visited an automotive
plant he was talking to potential voters
ahead of ahead of a primary right yeah
and then he flipped out when a worker
asked him about guns telling him that he
was full of crap and
this is a guy who's that keep mine this
is a guy there to see Joe Biden in the
face
well over AR 13 if the chanc weaker said
mistake to make if you know nothing
about firearms even though you seek to
legislate them they'll know numbers and
he was threatening to slap one of his
own voters to be clear this is example
number five will go through five
examples this is one this is an event
someone asked by about divorce not to be
clear this guy was kind of trolling Joe
Biden a little bit but when Joe Biden
says what you see here he didn't know it
at the time no we rely began to see why
your wife left you why your first wife
is deceased something that does concern
me and we've talked about how he had
dementia now it's the cool thing to do I
was I was the Joe Biden dementia hipster
I was talking about his duel where I
said I'm genuinely concerned for him
yeah if you notice in these it's him not
finishing phrases at all yeah that's
what's concerning to me not that he's
saying things that are nonsensical that
he also if you look at sort of the the
way that he is moving his but it seems
like his mouth doesn't work he's
punch-drunk yeah the nanobots can't
control his mouth yeah he's losing his
train of thought and he's just stumbling
along trying to find the right words
okay so most this will this no believe
me you are you okay
Jerald almost here is another and there
are several of these examples there's so
many that we had to just pick I think we
have to on this list but here he is
talking to one of his voters who has a
question about oil pipelines and by the
way this is also slinging loans as a
trend his own supporters if they ask him
legitimate questions
he just dismisses them
no I'm just asking you a legitimate
question about oil pipelines this is
kind of the reason for a caucus for
upfront ways to find out their issue are
you or just word he's gonna I'm voting
Tom Steyer I guess there is there are
other ones grabs his jacket
Joe Biden he's lucky someone doesn't
kick his ass yeah yeah it's true here's
something I think it's an important
example to when we're talking about
Donald Trump and and Joe Biden people
say Donald Trump is crazy or Donald
Trump has typos in his tweets sure
that's because he's a relative yes right
and he tweets like he speaks but when he
speaks
Donald Trump is able to finish his
thought so oh yeah the people who hate
Donald Trump they immediately hate what
Donald Trump is about to say when he
starts his sentence because they know
how it's going to end right the people
who don't like Joe Biden have to sit and
rap the country have no idea like Donald
Rose must say excuse me
listen my wall okay it's gonna be a best
wall always worse Jill my book okay
listen my wall I he dumped he didn't do
the you know the thing and he's not even
you're not gonna find him there what if
Joe Biden isn't capable I mean I mean
mentally like he wouldn't be able to
what it what if his mental faculties
deteriorate further after you've already
voted right now like right now is there
is somebody gonna come up and say well
hey wait a minute like this keeps go by
faculties to deteriorate further he
would have to be just a head in a jar
that you go see in a tent as well
notification bell if you're subscribed
to hit all notifications because
apparently just a notification Bell
doesn't mean a whole lot and turn them
on on your app and on your phone new
videos go up every day at nine or eight
Eastern nine eight nine Eastern nine
nine Eastern if you're not subscribed
just check in and please do Canada yes
that's right okay let's example number
three he goes through this again we took
a bit of a detour there he goes a step
further when he's asked about the high
number of illegals in the country
illegal immigrants who were
pour it under OPA so here's someone who
is actually he doesn't even get to
finish his question from what I
understand the guy is actually further
to the left of Joe Biden here you go
Ellis wife no no see I'm just saying you
ate a lot of deportations going Trump
you always what it's wrong no no no I
don't want Trump no that's not what I
want I just want you to just run into
the arms of another okay he's literally
like oh you're gonna vote for me you
might vote for me I'll slap you in the
bring up any criticism this could be the
two thinnest skin the candidates yeah I
wouldn't be surprised of a debate it's
just Donald Trump saying you said bad
stuff about me
no I things about me no excuse me you
should bad thing for no you so I'm gonna
take you out by the widget you don't
have a woodshed you couldn't afford to
watch it I shall show you my sit by pay
stubs in as a vice prep why'd you stop
because you're I think it was a toss-up
between the number one example of number
two so these are kind of interchangeable
no but this one is pretty bad this lit
the internet ablaze he doesn't respond
well to again questions about his
electability look at this insult that he
throws back at this woman so how do you
explain the performance in Iowa and why
should the voters believe that you can
win the national election middle caucus
no you haven't you're a lying dog face
pony soldier you said you are but you
know you gotta be honest I'm gonna be
out there with Charlie Sheen's
droopy-eyed armless children he's
running for president where is this like
a saying anywhere
looks like a dog a little bit there well
this is but she's like a cute one is
this like a movie rain but audio it was
saying like people were coming through
the back has never said a news never
said and by the way this is somebody who
was enough of a supporter to get like
prime seating right behind the stage
with you know yes you know what this
this this tells me more so obviously
we're laughing it kind of goes back to
when Obama said Oh people's not my mom
always used to say don't get all we-we'd
up and why and people looked it up like
no that's a term that was never ever
used yeah just like Joe Biden this is
emblematic of the same problem where he
remember you talked about every morning
I go down to Amy's diner and I grab a
cup of coffee and he's down I've been
closed for 26 years yeah it's not just
that he misspeaks
it's that they don't see any kind of
accountability from the media Barack
Obama just thought well I'll just say we
eat up as a term and that'll be the end
of it and Joe Biden just thought I'll
say pup what it lying Pony phones I'll
just say it was a John Wayne film and no
like this right it's not a real thing
Twitter isn't gonna happen
he just you know there's people
embellish right this happens people
embellish stories and I miss shows
sometimes because we're obviously trying
to entertain you or we take a story and
you amplify it maybe it's a date and you
turned up to attend Joe Biden creates
stories about people he's never met with
places that he's never been in
restaurants and establishments that
don't even exist he's very creative
everybody first became VP here's like I
was gonna meet I met the Pope and public
no never definitely you never sensed me
buddy watched his red shoe and I said
hey you don't mess with Joe and white it
why who stopped his example for if you
were expecting something more
substantial with it no so
funny to me and that's the thing as if
he runs for president I don't really
know this go home is substantial the
bank no you know the only vote he'll get
is a sympathy vote at that point like I
stopped punching him he's down yeah we
got to be careful I think of anything
Donald Trump needs to pull back a little
bit yeah cuz otherwise I can just look
like you much it could look like you
know a clockwork orange with the hobo
yeah yeah this one it's tough to hear if
you're listening on the audio come on
come on that's enough guys this one is
so it's it's it's tough that you you'll
miss it if you if you just if you skip a
beat but it's so childish it's so petty
when he's been asked but he's asked by
this guy about the potential baggage of
his son ties ties with the Ukraine just
watch he didn't say you're fat you said
look fat just challenged this push-ups
yes and the man didn't actually happens
really is this not you grabbing judgment
I'll give you that I love how the ladies
turn this into like American Ninja
Warrior only their feats of strength
watch me roll this frying pan exploded
using your obvious I'll use nothing but
my lungs who's stopped I love just call
them fat egos but listen here fat you
know look here fat ass you know whatever
it is if someone might say who's trying
to insult someone and be a little bit
more
little biting make it sting he just
calls him he calls him in fat like a
like it's a proper noun like that listen
here fact nothing I mean there's so many
options you could go to you like you can
make it stain and by the way I thought
maybe cuz the guy wasn't really that fat
he was not he was a little overweight
when I thought him maybe that's Joe
Biden showing because you know what if
you really want to make someone
self-conscious you don't pick the person
who's obese and call them fat there any
other obese you pick the guys maybe put
on a few pounds and it'll you'll live
rent-free inside his head forever but I
don't think Joe Biden is that kind of
foresight the kind of thing Donald Trump
would do yeah that was a master yeah and
I wouldn't be surprised if he does that
during the debates we're you know Joe
Biden gets up maybe has an unflattering
suit and Donald Trump gets up and goes
like hey listen all right we're gonna
enjoy ourselves tonight just like you do
at the buffet table right we see that
Joe I'm kidding Captain Crunch YZ or
just like subtly reminds him where he is
like what city he's in just to make sure
everybody knows we're in Raleigh nor
[Laughter]
deny where he's going and I want to
challenge Joe by into a push-up contest
or fights that he has not done either of
those things you gotta do that under
jury you know how they did like the
under drew bass undercover drew they
would get the guy the undercover Maru
yeah yeah so pro basketball player who
would then go at is out his uncle Drew
and they would like put this
professional makeup on him and he'd go
out there and like how old around and
hey let me just play and they'd be like
all right
and you go like do beach ball and then
they go out there and then you just be
like dunking on them yeah you got to do
that that would be amazing old man and
then you get up out of your wheelchair
and out push-up hammers look look look
we could easily make you look like
Gerald and no one would do that like you
could do a push-up now now I'm psyching
myself up because he seems so confident
maybe can know maybe he's just insane
but no one but I tell you what I think
it's going to be Joe Biden and I am
really let me know what you are looking
forward to most of those debates for me
it's hopefully that you'll buy net one
but I think I don't want to say I'm
looking forward to it but I think what
will be the climb
of the debates is Donald Trump will
enter probably the stage right stage
left I don't know let's assume a stage
right fireworks and he'll come out and
he'll do his thing right he'll probably
insult somebody good for him and then
Joe Biden will come out and there's a
many any poops so hey if you enjoyed
this video subscribe or hit the
notification bell and hit all
notifications because not all
notifications work now if you just hit
the normal notification Bell I think
there's some videos playing in boxes but
of course you consider subscribing at
ladder of credit comm slash Mudd Club
because there's a bunch of content that
could never make it onto YouTube and I
think the box is playing there's a video
playing in a box with